I was told that I should come and talk
about the 10 lessons I've learned in my
career and I realized I've had a lot
more than 10 so I've never given this
talk before so I'm I've got a few notes
with me and I'm gonna I just scrub build
some thought stuff up on the board so
you're seeing it in sort of like a like
a start up kind of mode because I've
given for speeches yesterday and three
today and this is the only one I'm gonna
give like this maybe in my life
depending upon how it goes but I'm gonna
start by actually tuck I'm gonna give
you the first three to four minutes of a
TED talk I gave last year on the subject
of intergenerational collaboration so
we'll start with that and then I'll get
into my my 10 lessons I've learned and
then we'll open it up to you so you can
ask me some questions and we have a
conversation so it was my third day on
the job at a hot Silicon Valley startup
in early 2013 I was more than I was more
than double the age of the dozen
engineers in the room I've been brought
into this hot startup because of my I
was a seasoned expert in my field but in
this particular group of geniuses young
geniuses and engineers I felt like a
complete newbie so I did everything I
could to actually be invisible and then
the wizard the 25 year old wizard who
was leaving the meeting turned to me and
said chip if you shipped a feature and
no one used it did it really ship I
looked at him my jaw dropped and I said
chip is in deep ship because I have no
idea what you're talking about there was
an awkward silence he moved on to
someone else I slid down in my chair and
I could not wait for that meeting to end
that was my introduction to Airbnb more
than six years ago I'd been asked by the
three millennial co-founders to come in
and be the head of global hospitality
and strategy as well as the in-house
mentor to Brian Chesky the seat
and co-founder now I'd spent from age 26
to 50 to being a boutique hotel
entrepreneur and so I had a lot of
hospitality knowledge accumulated but
after my first week on the job at Airbnb
I realized that the brave new home
sharing world didn't need most of my
old-school bricks and mortar insights
hospitality insights a stark reality
rocked me what in the hell do I have to
offer these people I'm twice their age
on average I've never worked in the tech
company by the way back then in early
2013 when Brian said to me when he was
trying to convinced me to join the
company he said I'm gonna Luber over to
your home and let's talk about it and I
said what's that
what's over I didn't have an uber or
lyft up on my phone in early 2013 so I
was in a place that was not my natural
habitat
I was also 52 years old which is not
exactly the age where people try new
things to sort of see if they're gonna
succeed or fail but instead of actually
turning my my nervousness my anxiety
into judgment against these young
geniuses I decided to see if I could
match my wise eyes with their fresh eyes
and I actually started to imagine myself
as almost like a modern Margaret Mead
amongst the Millennials because I
actually got curious I got curious about
what we can learn from each other and I
came to realize that we had a lot to
learn from each other so that brought me
to a point in my first few months at
Airbnb about six years ago where I
started to ask the question why is it
that we as different generations we have
five generations in the workplace for
the very first time why is it that we
almost treat each other like separate
countries on the same continent we
actually haven't learned how to open up
the the borders and the dialects so we
can actually learn from each other and I
truly believe that one of the critical
trade agreements of our time in the 21st
century is learning how to create an
intergenerational potluck that all of us
can actually take advantage of
so that's my those are the first few
thoughts from my TED talk last year and
as as Tina said my background is I I was
here went to undergrad Business School
here started my company Juwanna vivre
Crew 252 hotels my last hotel that we as
a company created was a place in
downtown Palo Alto called the Epiphany
that Larry Ellison bought you know and
and he came in and out to the know blue
hotel so I loved I loved that part of my
career until I actually didn't and
during my ten lessons you'll hear a
little bit more about that and then more
recently I created something called the
modern Elder Academy which is the first
midlife wisdom school in the world and
during Q&A you can ask a little bit more
about that Tina actually got a little
taste of it and it's a place where
people can actually reframe their
mindset to look forward to actually the
extra years we have in our life I'm 58
now and a year ago I was scuba diving
with my father in Indonesia my father at
that time was ATS 81 now so I was one of
those online sites and I looked at okay
well what how long am I gonna live and
so I just put in a bunch of information
there obviously didn't have my genome
study or anything like that but they
actually spit back after about a 20
minute thing they said came back he said
you're probably gonna live to about age
98 so I went downstairs to go out scuba
diving with my dad for the morning and I
asked my dad how long are you gonna live
dad and he said ninety-eight so that's
interesting let's do the math dad if
you're 80 years old now what percentage
of your adult life is still ahead of you
well actually if you're 80 you've got
sixty two years behind you 18 years
ahead of you you're barely into the
fourth quarter of your adulthood me I
was 57 last year at that time if I
actually do live till 98 that means like
I'm not even halfway through my
adulthood yet that kind of thinking is
what led me to sort of asking the
question why is it that we don't
actually out don't create midlife wisdom
schools so people can actually reimagine
and repurpose themselves and shift their
mindset so I'll talk a little bit more
about that in the QA so what I'm gonna
jump into now is my 10 lessons now I
wasn't gonna give a talk about 10
lessons but actually when they were
telling me about what this program is
about I figured ok yeah they said come
and talked about your 10 lessons so I
took it seriously I thought about a lot
and I said okay over the last week I
came up with my 10 lessons and I've got
them up here on the board so part it's a
lot yeah I'll give you fuel stories
along the way as well so my first lesson
and yet this is very old school no
PowerPoint no so that and you probably
can't even read that but you'll hear me
say it so the first lesson is learn the
difference between a fixed and a growth
mindset Carol Dweck great psychologists
here at Stanford popularized the idea
that we can actually have a fixed or a
growth mindset when you have a fixed
mindset you have a tendency to want to
prove yourself and for you success is
defined by winning and I in some parts
of our life that may be how we operate
and the beauty in that is you win a lot
the the sadness about that is you
actually play in a relatively small
sandbox because if you actually believe
that winning if success is defined by
winning you don't try things that you're
not going to win a growth mindset on the
other hand is not about proving yourself
that's about improving yourself and so
if you're actually focused on improving
yourself success is not about winning
it's about learning and that's not it
just you know something that's
appropriate for someone who's young it's
someone at any age can be learning so I
have you know one of the things I did
when I joined Airbnb and started
mentoring Brian the CEO is I taught him
about the idea of a fixed versus a
growth mindset and how could we create a
company than add a growth mindset I also
sort of took advantage of a relationship
that I've had for maybe 10 years now
with a guy named mohali csikszentmihalyi
you know who that is so the guy who he
popularized the concept of flow the idea
of being in the flow what brings you in
the flow and one of the things he taught
me was the following this is the flow
diagram on that on the vertical axis
challenge on the horizontal is skill
what he taught me was this
when you're in the flow are in the zone
you're in a place where you sort of feel
like you are in exactly where you're
supposed to be and you're tapping into
your natural your natural talents he
says what you do is you actually in
order to get into the flow zone which is
about it the 45-degree angle here you
actually have to do the following
physics you have to go up and then over
what does that mean it means you
actually have to go challenge skill
challenge skill challenge skill if you
don't do challenge skill if you sort of
if you say I'm just gonna do skill and
no challenge where do you end up the
places a lot of people end up in midlife
boredom
down here now it's on the other hand
you're only doing the challenge and not
building the skill you end up in anxiety
the better your mindset the more you
actually expand your mindset such that
you have a growth mindset the the wider
this arrow is now that's my own little
conceit of what I've you know neck
mixing Carol Dweck's worth what work
with Mahalo accept me as work is if you
have a very skinny flow zone you have a
fixed mindset and if you have a very
wide one you're open to learning and
building a skill even though it's hard
I'm 58 years old I've learned how to
surf at 58 and I'm learning Spanish for
the first time I'm not very good at
either but I've learned X if you have
fun it's easier to try a new skill and
once I understand understood the
challenge skill to step I understood
that's the only way I was going to get
better so that is a first lesson I'll
also say that this idea of a modern
elder just to speak to that for a second
is somebody who is as curious as they
are wise now that's the that's I think
the shift from the elder of the past the
elder of the password and the
traditional elder dispensed wisdom and
frankly in a society especially
agricultural societies where things
didn't change much over time the fact
that your 75 year old grandpa was
telling you about land wisdom was
valuable to you but today we live in a
different
no doubt and in fact being an elder
isn't all that cool anymore
especially in the United States but I
distinguish elder versus elderly elderly
maybe the last 10 years of your life
being an elder means it's a relative
term it's a relative word it's a word
that describes you relative to those
around you
if you're 42 years old surrounded by 22
year olds you're probably an elder at
air B&B at 52 and now 58 because I'm
still there as a strategic advisor after
four years a full-time I am an elder
everybody no doubt and it was Joe Gebbia
one of the co-founders who started
calling me that within the company so I
actually think a modern elder and we
need to sort of understand what if we're
gonna live 10 years longer and power is
moving 10 years younger in in the
digital society what do you do with
people in midlife who still have some
wisdom well I think you actually feed
them the idea of curiosity how do you
build a curiosity and you make sure that
they understand that this being an elder
is not about reverence anymore it's
about relevance and relevance requires a
certain amount of curiosity and a
willingness to learn something new which
requires that challenge skill all right
that's the first one let's go to number
2 of chips lessons that he's learning
his career experience what it means to
be the other now this is an interesting
one I liked writing this one down partly
because it's not necessarily one that
you would you would expect what it says
is first of all we know about diversity
and inclusion and belonging the idea of
diversity inclusion lots of evidence
that it actually works in the workplace
diverse workplaces when it comes to
gender are 15 percent more successful
according to McKinsey and diverse
workplaces when it comes to race or 35
percent more effective in terms of what
comes out of them when it comes to age
tons of evidence that age diverse teams
do better
partly because young people are
exceptionally good at focus older people
we know what we lose brain wise as we
get older right what do we lose did you
already forget I'm
you lose memory that's a joke
you you get older and your memories not
as good and you're maybe not as quick as
you used to be but the thing that a lot
of people don't know about the aging
brain or the mature brain is you
actually get more adept at doing the
left-brain right-brain tango you
actually do all wheel drive of your
brain you actually are more able to
synthesize left and right brain why is
that valuable it means you can actually
see you can sort of connect the dots and
synthetically see holistic things that
someone else might not be able to see
you have that kind of person on a team
while you also have a young person who's
like brilliant about some specific
things that can be a great team well so
I think diversity is really essential
but I don't say this necessarily purely
for effectiveness I don't say it unless
I purely for political correct reasons
but I say it frankly for your own
benefit if the part of what I'm talking
about today isn't the lessons I've
learned a lesson I've learned is when I
was the other I learned what it meant to
be more empathetic and when I was an
empathetic leader I understood what a
person was feeling in the room so I was
at the other in high school I went to a
place called Long Beach Poly High School
Snoop Dogg's high school you know Snoop
Dogg look at the back yes yes
sniffing low means probably okay so you
know what it is it's an inner-city high
school they called me curious white boy
because I was curious about other
cultures but I learned luckily in my
high school years as a white guy what it
meant to be the other then at age 22 I
came out as a gay man in a fraternity
having played water polo at Stanford
that was also being the other and it
Airbnb
absolutely no doubt as a 52 year-old
amongst 26 year olds I was the other but
that ability to be the other truly
tenderized my heart and my ability to
understand other people better than
anything else
I've ever had in my life so when you can
especially for those of you in the room
who are white male and straight figure
out an opportunity to be the other
whether that means living in a foreign
country for a period of time
or joining a group that's very different
than you demographically it will
actually make you a better human over
time beyond just being a better leader
all right number three surround yourself
with people who you want to become now
it's possible that nothing will
influence you more in your life than the
collection of people you surround
yourself with I went to Stanford
Business School here I didn't like it a
whole lot to be honest with you I'm a
Type A competitive person and I was
surrounded by type-a competitive people
and I sort of felt at times like I was
just being a rebel and a radical just to
be different than everybody else well
for me this lesson surround yourself
with people you want to become was I
started seeing that out of out of
Business School I was hanging out with
artists a lot and I think it was partly
because there was a piece of me I took
as an undergrad here at Stanford I took
a lot of studio art classes but felt
like you know not very practical but I
started hanging out with artists and
massage therapists that there's some
real benefits of that if you have
massage therapists as friends and what
what else writers and even as shaman one
of my closest friends is a shaman today
so why do I say that I say you know what
the thing that's really interesting
about life is hanging out with people
who think differently than you do and
absolutely helpful when you're
struggling with something you know when
I've struggled in business I've actually
found I've gotten better advice from
friends of mine who have no idea about
anything in business doesn't mean that
you can't get some good advice for
another business person but often
they're gonna say something to you that
you might have already thought of
yourself so all I can say is surround
yourself with people you want to become
or who actually are different than you
again
number two and number three have a
little bit of similarities number four
is force rank your top five preferences
when it comes to job opportunities so I
say this to you for those of you in the
room who are undergrad or graduate
school you're going to have some job
offers you're going to have the choices
of location the nature of the company
the nature of the title you'll have how
money you'll be may you'll be making
what's who you'll be reporting to there
are a lot of different variables that
define how you make that decision my
recommendation to you again those of you
who are this is true I think for any of
us in the room but the younger you are
in the room this I think is particularly
predominant the amount of money you make
in your first job out of college or
graduate school has almost zero
correlation to how much wealth if
financial wealth is what you're looking
to actually create there's almost zero
correlation to it so my recommendation
is you first rank your top five five
preferences when it comes to job
opportunities and you make sure that
money is not in the top three unless you
absolutely need money to pay back your
loans which is for a lot of people true
but the natural tendency because it is
absolutely benchmark able is that use
money as one of the predominant ways to
actually judge the offers you have I
will tell you a personal story for me so
I hurt between my first and second year
of Business School I went to work for
Morgan Stanley in New York and their
real estate division I did well they
liked me a lot you know they wanted me
to come back they gave me an offer I
turned it down they gave me a second
offer and you know it was back then in
1984 which is when this was happening it
was a lot of money it was like 80 to
$100,000 which back then was a lot of
money I was actually think it was
actually $100,000 including that
guaranteed bonus I took a job out of
Stanford Business School in 1984 for
$24,000 your salary
maybe I'm done the next actually they
stack they one of the people in the
career development section of the
business school pulled me aside one day
and said do you know that the next
highest person they couldn't tell me who
it was in terms of what their what the
next lowest salary was after my twenty
four thousand it was fifty five thousand
so there's like I was way off the bell
curve but the lesson for me is this I
knew I wanted to be an entrepreneur when
I grew up I knew I wanted to be a real
estate entrepreneur and I wanted to do
something
creating interesting projects so rather
than go to work for Morgan Stanley out
of Business School making about $100,000
a year I was in a lucky position that I
didn't have a lot of student loans and I
actually was able to take a job that
paid me $24,000 a year but did promise
that within a year if I was doing well
I'd become a partner in the business
which I did and within a year after that
we were looking at doing a hotel project
which introduced in San Francisco which
introduced me to the idea of hotels
which led me to saying I would like to
be a real estate person but specializing
in hospitality so two and a half years
after I graduated from business school I
started a boutique hotel company and
grew it to the second largest in the US
at age 26 I started that if I had gone
to work for Morgan Stanley that would
never have happened I'm not saying it
wouldn't have been a bad path I might
have learned how to become an
institution or real estate person but
that wasn't what I was looking for so if
you get too wetted by the one thing
that's most easy to benchmark which is
your salary you actually give extra
weight to something that in the long
term may not matter all that much to you
all right going on to number five find a
mindfulness practice that suits you more
mindful less monkey when it comes to
your mind why don't have this one here I
have this one here because we as humans
and we as generally high achievers use
all kinds of things to actually settle
down our mind most of them give us a
little bit of an intoxication effect
whether it's alcohol or pot or
prescriptive drugs or a variety of other
things that we get obsessive about
sometimes we might even get addictive
about things as our way to have a
diversion well I was lucky enough I have
never liked yoga I've been trying to do
it for 35 years I'm okay at it at best
I'm a way way way focus too much on how
do I compare with everybody else in the
room but when it comes to meditation
been doing it for 35 years thank God for
meditation you generally close your eyes
because I'm not comparing myself with
anybody else
and I'm just allowing myself to go a
little deeper now why is all this
relevant here's how it's relevant I
think there are two kinds of modes of
operation of how we show up in the world
it's either attain or attune and
sometimes you want to be on one's path
the attained the path and that's been
most of my life and other times you want
to be on the attuned path the truth is
there are effects on both when you're in
the attain mode all the time you
actually sometimes have sharp elbows and
everybody has to get out of your way and
you have to atone for things later so a
team can lead to a tone a tune can lead
to feeling at one a sense of harmony
with your surroundings for me as a type
a competitive person the process of
learning when in my life I need to be in
the attained mode and when I know in my
life I need to be in the attune mode has
been probably one of the most valuable
things I've learned in my whole life and
it's helped me to not get addicted to a
bunch of other things that we tend to
use to slow our mind down so I highly
recommend it doesn't have to be
meditation whatever thing actually you
know for some one of my best friends
it's surfing
that's his form of mindfulness so find
something that actually helps you to
moderate that monkey mind it'll we'll
see you know be very good for you that
for the rest of your life
number six is seek a mentor even if
they're not someone you've even met so I
was brought into Airbnb to become Brian
Chesky in-house mentor as I wrote about
in my book wisdom at work the making of
a modern elder I learned within the
first week that I was not there to
actually be Brian's mentor exclusively I
was there also to be his intern I was
the mentor and the intern at the same
time how many buddy how many people saw
Robert De Niro the intern Anne Hathaway
so I had the opposite experience of
Robert De Niro Robert De Niro came to
the in the movie he was a 70 year old
intern who was going to actually help
the CEO to be brought in as an intern
but he ended up becoming the mentor for
Anne Hathaway
I was brought in as the mentor who ended
up becoming the intern because I needed
to learn Tech I didn't understand tech
at all and so my process of actually
learning Tech had a lot to do with Brian
I I'd say that what we had was that we
had a trade agreement where I gave him
EQ emotional intelligence which is
something you tend to build over the
course of a lifetime and he gave me DQ
which was digital intelligence and so
that was the trade agreement we had so
my experience with this one is
interesting because my the two most
profound mentors I've ever had in my
life I never met interesting the first
one was a guy named Herb Kelleher so
Herb Kelleher was the founding CEO of
Southwest Airlines and with after a
couple years of starting my company and
I was growing the company we're going to
have a second in a third hotel I wrote
to the CEO of Southwest Airlines based
in Dallas I wrote a letter because
that's what we used to do so I wrote a
letter and said will you help me I may
at that point a 28 year old CEO I'm
growing my company I like your culture
the culture of your company is
incredible and I said can you teach me a
few things
three weeks later I received a letter
back from Herb Kelleher saying yes I
will help you I guess you know I did
letter I wrote was pretty pretty I guess
was poignant or something and he just he
said I'll help you so for the next ten
years about once a year I'd write him a
letter we never had a phone call never
had a phone call we just wrote letters
to each other now similarly I wrote one
letter to a guy named Peter Drucker and
I think Peter Drucker was the first
modern elder before we actually had a
phrase modern elder Peter Drucker lived
to the age of 95 he wrote of his 40
books he wrote two-thirds of them he
wrote after age 65 he's the one who
popularized the idea of the knowledge
worker in 1959 I think today it's we
don't need knowledge workers anymore we
need wisdom workers because knowledge is
all in our in our smartphone but both of
these guys I wrote Peter Drucker he
wrote me back so just know that
sometimes
we think that you know there's not a
mentor in our midst but there may be
somebody out there you could write or so
you can reach out to or in the world we
live in today you can learn so much
about someone else who you may never
meet and just learn everything you can
about them and then use that as your
form of DIY do-it-yourself mentorship
from somebody you might never even meet
alright number seven your reputation is
portable and is delivered by the cosmic
bellhop a little hotel joke there
practise karmic capitalism and your
reputation will flourish so that guide
mohali Csikszentmihalyi who came up with
the whole flow concept he said something
to me
he and his wife what a sweet man he
invited me to come up to Montana he
lives in Southern California he invited
me to come up to Montana in the summer
with for three days to hang out with him
and his wife at their their summer home
in Montana tiny little cottage I mean
really I was like I felt like I was
family and on that during that time I
learned so much from him and so he
served was a mentor as well but one of
the things he said to me that was so
critical in terms of my memory of it was
he said you can tell who's powerful in
the society by that how tall the
buildings are and he said 150 years ago
it used to be religion was the most
powerful part of a society and the
Cathedral in town often was the tallest
building in town and then 50 years ago
it actually was City Hall or some
government building that actually sort
of predominated over a skylight and then
that still true in a lot of cities where
the City Hall is the biggest structure
in a city the tallest structure in fact
in some cities it can't be any taller
you can't build a taller building than
the City Hall but today he says you know
it's all about skyscrapers and so who
has the power today
muhuali said he also known as Mike Mike
said power is in business and he said
what's going to happen as a result of
that is people are going to expect more
of you business people and he says and
this is ten years ago this is before
really I think we have the kind of
transparency we have today with the
internet and social media he said people
are going to know whether you're
greenwashing something whether whether
you're sincere about how you show up as
a business leader and as a company and
with your values and people will choose
to buy based upon your values well he
was absolutely right there's obviously
some evidence already at that point so I
call this karmic capitalism what goes
around comes around and it ends so it's
been sort of a big part of my way of
doing business for a long time and the
story I'll tell here is there's a hotel
in San Francisco called the hotel
vitaliy it's on the waterfront it's
across the street from the Ferry
Building it's on city land and back
about 20 years ago we were competing
with four other developers to build a
new hotel on city land and we were
competing the big the big gorilla in
this match was Kimpton bill Kimpton and
his company Kimpton Hotels which
ultimately became the largest boutique
hotel company in the US we became the
second largest and we were both in San
Francisco but 20 years ago we were still
a relatively small company so we were
competing with Kimpton and I'll never
forget when we were doing our
presentations we did our presentation
there were four of us you know is a
three-hour presentation we were like
psyched oh I think they really liked us
and we came down the elevator and when
we got to the the ground floor the
person who was right in front of us as
the door opened was Bill Kimpton and 16
people on his staff who were there to
actually do the presentation and we had
been so excited I was like oh
they're gonna win they're the big guys
he's got a lot of money we don't have a
ton of money but long story short is
karmic capitalism ruled now it was a
process where there are a lot of
different you know opportunities to have
that the citizens of San Francisco speak
up about who should do this hotel and
the guy Mike Casey who ran the hotel
Union in San Francisco spoke up on our
on our side instead of on Kempton side
but more importantly because we had done
a lot of things with local nonprofits
like we were actually part of our we did
part of thing we do with our general
managers is we didn't just judge our
general managers based upon
profitability and market share and
employee and customer satisfaction we
actually judge them and actually
evaluated them based upon how much money
they gave away based upon
profit groups using our meeting space
and hotel rooms as a in-kind
contribution so what happened without us
even knowing is and we did something
called the celebrity pool toss which is
a fundraiser for kids in the Tenderloin
and something called the hotel Heroes
award which was like the like the Oscars
for lying level employees at hotels so
we certainly had the karmic capitalism
momentum behind this but it was sort of
hard to toot our own horn
well what ended up happening is one of
the nonprofits in town the Tenderloin
Neighborhood Development Corporation TN
DC went out and they got a dozen other
nonprofits to come together and write a
letter and talk about what kind of
influence we had had as a company on the
San Francisco nonprofit scene and at the
end of the day what we were told is even
though we offered less money than
Kimpton did for this 55 or 65 year lease
long lammles they gave the they gave the
contract to us for the long land lease
because of that reputation
so do know that you know sharp elbows
especially when you in the attain mode
may mean that you you know create a few
bloody noses around people around you
but recognize that your reputation
precedes you
and that's true as best as individuals
as well as a company number eight is
develop a workplace skill that is
valuable no matter where you live or
what industry you're working in so think
about that for a moment
what is skill the people are going to
look to you 30 years from now 40 years
from now 20 years now and say that
person she or he you are the best in the
world at that what could that be
now there we have a little bit of
history with a something called ek guy
how many of you have seen this before
okay very few so you guy is you know
it's I know it's really small up your
sauce apologize for that take a picture
of it or actually right now I can see it
on the camera up there it's actually
you'll be able to see it and
later their four components here what
you love what you're good at what the
world needs and what you get paid what
you can be paid for right there in the
middle if you can find the sweet spot of
something that has all four of those
things that's a that's a perfect fit
most of us don't have that and if you're
actually have one eat two of these
primarily it's either a profession a
passion a mission or a vocation well for
me gosh I was lucky very early on I
realized I was fascinated by cultural
trends I'm really interested in where
things are going to be ten years from
now
how are people how are people how are
people changing their behaviors and so
long story short is every time we
created a boutique hotel 52 of them it
was based upon a different magazine and
five adjectives because we thought
magazines are sort of ahead of the trend
usually and so that first hotel the
Phoenix that rock and roll hotel was
based upon Rolling Stone magazine and we
came up with five adjectives that define
Rolling Stone magazine funky irreverent
adventurous cool and young at heart and
we created a hotel that had that
personality what we didn't know at the
time and what became the magic is we
came to realize that we were not just in
the business of creating cool boutique
hotels but the people who fell in love
with that hotel almost thought of it as
a habitat their perfect habitat and it
was like an identity refreshment because
the people who love the Phoenix are
funky irreverent adventurous cool and
young at heart
and this is true of boutique hotels the
place you love the most probably has
adjectives or qualities about it that
most define it define you aspirationally
that learning that at a very young age
and then building that skill to
understand
six and six years in the six years and
four months ago that as most of my hotel
your friends looked at me and said why
would you ever want to go work for
Airbnb Home Sharing sucks no one
actually is it's just a millennial thing
well I said you know what I think
actually I think Airbnb is just the next
cultural thing after boo
Hotels it's just taking boutique hotels
10 steps further about a localized
experience and so being able to see a
trend I think I'm seeing a trend right
now with the modern elder Academy the
idea of creating the world's first
midlife wisdom school so just so that's
my that's maybe my gift that's the thing
that I've been able to learn what's
yours what's the thing that you are
going to be able to find maybe in that
exact center spot where you have a
nikkie guy number nine is find or create
a leadership point of view that serves
you in good times and bad and that you
can teach to other people at sustenance
your leadership legacy I'm going to show
you something that's way way too small
for anybody to be able to see it I think
how does it go that's right thank you
but I wrote it I wrote a book twelve
years ago called peek how great
companies get their mojo from Maslow and
I was fascinated by Maslow Abraham
Maslow Cade the hierarchy of needs which
is on the right hand side there but was
it was curious to me at the time I
started using it and I didn't I didn't
write the book I basically used it in
the company and because I saw it worked
so well ultimately we end up writing a
book about it but what was curious to me
was Maslow had five levels of the
pyramid right so it starts with
physiological goes up to
self-actualization but there's basically
three paradigms on those five levels
there's survival which is the first two
levels there's six which is
physiological and safety
there's success which is what you feel
when you social esteem I'm sorry social
belonging and esteem needs are being met
and then there's the top of the pyramid
when you're self actualized state you're
in a transformational state you've
transformed so what I was curious about
is since companies are full of humans
let's take this human hierarchy of needs
theory and apply it using survival
succeed transform to a pyramid that has
employees customers and investors and in
the middle is this karmic capitalism of
you create a great culture and you make
your employees happy that leads to
customers being happy which tends to
lead
your growth which leads to investors
being happy and then you invest back in
culture that's my model that's the model
that will be my leadership legacy it's
the one that I taught my 3,500 employees
in Surat Aviv including all of our
housekeepers and our bellman everybody
learned that it's actually part of the
reason why Brian Chesky called me he
said we're intrigued by that peak thing
we'd like to have it here at Airbnb and
that was when we were a tiny company
with 300 people in it not tiny but it
was not what it is today which is 20
times larger so that's what's led me
frankly to have a number of young
entrepreneurs come to me and say yes I'd
like to see how we could apply that
model here there's all kinds of
leadership legacies there's all kind of
business models out there there's
servant leadership there's Richard
Branson said to me his his whole
business philosophy was I am the market
his whole president he'll premise behind
business was I'm the market I better be
delighted by what we create well that's
ok but that's probably not a full
leadership model John Mackey from Whole
Foods Markets has this conscious
capitalism model you don't have to go
out and create a model and write books
or anything like that but being able to
get to a place in your career where you
can articulate down to either something
you can put on paper or something you
could maybe summarize in a paragraph
such that people who are working with
you can understand it is a legacy that
you can offer to other people so that is
number nine and the number 10 is don't
tie your sense of self worth to your net
worth and create some emotional
insurance in your group of friends what
I've seen way too many times and it has
been true in my life as well is the
emotional rollercoaster of having a
company that goes up and down and up and
down becomes your own personal
rollercoaster
I remember in the early days of the
Phoenix I'm this young boutique hotel or
create my first hotel friends would come
up to me and say chip how are you doing
and my immediate response would be the
Phoenix is doing great and then finally
one person pulled me aside and said no
chip how are you doing personally and I
was like
I don't know the Phoenix is doing great
but my sense of self-worth was almost
exclusively connected to the success or
failure of my business now that is
dangerous when you hit a Great Recession
and I had five friends three of them
entrepreneurs commit suicide in 2008 to
2010 partly because their sense of
self-esteem was way too connected to the
company's fortune so let me just finish
by saying on that very silver note you
can have emotional insurance in your
life this is particularly true for the
men in the room who aren't usually as
good at this as the women you can be
vulnerable with some friends you can
have it maybe a couple of their
entrepreneurs who you have as your
little support group but just remember
that your sense of who you are and what
you've done in the world is much bigger
than the number of zeroes you have on
your balance sheet